[Musique]
ce soir nous sommes au waldorf astoria
versailles trianon palace pour déguster
un barbecue un peu particulier le
trianon champêtre
[Musique]
pour nous parler de ce trianon champagne
dos aux côtés du chef alors chef
pourquoi avez vous voulu créer ce
barbecue ici bonsoir en fait c'était une
belle occasion pour nous de travailler
autour d'une offre barbecue en fait à
notre à notre terrasse du bar c'est un
endroit qui est très vivant tous les
étés donc de mettre en place une offre
live cooking de cuisiner devant les
clients je trouvais ça très intéressant
d'apporter ça comme expérience au
waldorf astoria versailles et qu'est ce
qu'il ya au menu alors du coup alors le
au menu on a travaillé sur une offre
terre et mer donc on a de l'agneau de
l'aveyron on a dû delonglée black angus
on a une poitrine de cochon aux épices
marine et épices cuisson lente et le
côté mer on a du poulpe des belles
gambas et un assortiment de légumes
grillés on a trois sauces barbecue
béarnaise une sauce chimichurri avec des
frites maison une petite salade verte
donc voilà c'est une offre complète on
peut explorer différents produits et on
est sûr d'une sélection de produits de
très bonne qualité et pourquoi le terre
et mer c'est assez à la mode moi ça me
rappelle le côté mixed grill en fait on
retrouve souvent
à l'international pour nos clients ça
pouvait embêter de retrouver cette offre
est de pouvoir découvrir un peu les bons
produits qu'on abat et côté boisson
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve avant d'un
partenariat avec perrier perrier jouët
et donc on a travaillé aussi pour avoir
justement notre offre culinaire qui se
coordonnent très bien avec
la sélection de champagne perrier jouët
est ce que ça fonctionne ce barbecue
champêtre j'ai l'impression que oui hein
ça fonctionne très bien depuis qu'on l'a
démarrée le les clients sont ravis
réserve assez rapidement on travaille
sur des sur du matériel ophir de qualité
donc ça tout de suite un cachet très
très sympa au milieu de notre verdure et
et oui ça fonctionne bien je vous laisse
travailler et nous on va déguster chiens
et maintenant c'est l'heure de déguster
avec quelques bulles justement qu'est ce
que vous me proposez vous propose
champagne blanc de blanc et les yeux et
écoutez c'est très bien
très très bon c'est mon péché mignon
[Musique]
très bon
si vous aussi vous voulez déguster ce
trianon champêtre c'est le jeudi soir le
vendredi soir et le samedi midi jusqu'à
septembre et le tarif est de 55 euros
par personne hors boissons
[Musique]